anzi
[Musica]
senza vivere mente di portare qualcosa
sul più bello
pensavi veramente di potermi tagliare i
capelli a piacimento
[Musica]
non pensavo mettessero dei rack per vero
e oltre milano allo schermo di solamente
reich è arrivato un massaggio cosa cosa
dice dobbiamo fare un'altra ricetta
un'altra ricetta orribile che farai un
ananas ripiena di formaggio avvolta dal
bacon e infine dalla pasta per la pizza
la nana scuola mezzala smettila di
piagnucolare stai zitto perché bisogna
per trucco e la 26 ago adesso fare
comiti di noi o scendere sotto e ti
stancherai un bel sorrisone prima faccia
di merda
dove andiamo in cucina
a
ciao ragazzi ben tornata in una puntata
di cucina buttata vedete questa qui è un
ananas che cosa faremo oggi con lei le
faremo tutto il male possibile e
immaginabile
dopo la ricetta della pasta americana
che vi lascio qua sopra se volete
recuperare quella ricetta ragazzi che mi
avete consigliato ma da almeno un anno
infatti alcuni di voi mi hanno scritto
su instagram
ma come dopo un anno che ti dico di
farla la fai adesso ragazzi non avevo le
forze comunque dopo questo momento di
entusiasmo in tanti ma avete suggerito
di replicare un ennesimo abominio
l'abominio che vedete in questo momento
è la roba che under madre santa che
andremo a fare oggi e se volete
prendervela con qualcuno non
prendetevela con me proprio tutte le
persone che erano sul madre santa
suggerito e poi lo assaggeremo e adesso
passiamo agli ingredienti
[Musica]
possiamo dire una cosa prima di iniziare
se già marca presolana marcio forse
sembra marcio vedere montare bella è
quello che conta perché ci vuole
solamente mettere sempre più in
difficoltà questa verità incinta un
ananas marcio
basta per la pizza la mozzarella brutta
e teme pd fette di bacon il momento per
prima cosa prendiamo l'ananas e
scopriamo se marcio davvero perfetto
marcio non è perfetto morbido non
sappiamo cosa stiamo facendo
vogliamo tutta quanta la buccia di fuori
e baciando solo parte sotto intatta non
sempre il mio pratico e martelli che
invece che questo col segreto occupo
questo senza sacchetto in peggio mazara
il coltello
pensavo andasse meglio è meglio questo
qui scende quel burro ma se dimezzando
una ragazza deve andare a filo della
goccia brave rai attivo del capo da
questa taglia perfetto tra ma cosa
effetto si sente se metti il dito a fine
corsa che succede non so se momento il
pisello ma con le cose che ci fa in
brodo ragazzi che va tolto resto è avere
un pelapatate a no scusami mi viene una
risposta tolgo perché se no capace che
poi diventa sgradevole
a questo punto dovremmo fare un
incisione acqui e creare un buco una
specie di imbuto umano ma creiamo un
alone al traffico solo far muro sono
geniali però almeno hai creato il succo
vedi un po che manca oggi è sul pezzo a
pezzo
adesso sto entrando con le dita nella
nona nel tentativo non capisco come
facciano nel video a tirarla fuori così
facilmente lo fanno vedere si che tutto
mi sembra troppo
iniziamo andare a tagliare pezzi via
pian piano è l'unica ma che schifo
perché sta tagliando sui fornelli perché
sta tagliando sui fornelli c'è perché
ero sia procedendo da un attimo non
rilevato nessun sapore strano
sinceramente comunque io non la mangio
così quello che sa fare il bagno nella
ma non l'ha bevuta questa sì che la
bevuta al forno e a 300.000 graham
angelo ma questo veramente deve curare e
odioso le sembra vero sparando in questo
dio mi stanno venendo dei pensieri o
simplicio è di tacchio quella pensione
di corri bridge con il mondo dormire
stasera cosa buona dei vostri metodi per
scoprire se la lancia in marcia non sono
efficaci diamo asciugata direi
all'ananas all'esterno visto che
dovremmo avvolgerla nella carta della
pixar
basta con della pasta della pizza e non
ce lo stiamo facendo per davvero
questo è proprio rientra nelle cose
senza senso della vita con sé stato
bravissimo è un mondo meno dibawatt
sembra assaggiamo un po di impasto della
pizza che schifo io taglio qua qua qua
qua
vogliamo allora io sto mettendo un
secondo questa cosa così schifo che
schifo
buonissimo no poco poi mangiate
l'impasto bruto sono me troveremo delle
pellicole che affermano questa cosa
allora abbiamo fatto la struttura con
filippo dicevo abbiamo fatto questa
struttura e adesso dovremo riempirla di
mozzarella e sera glitches la che ci
troviamo la pasta della pizza avevamo la
mozzarella ci mancava il pomodoro ci
facciamo la pizza la pizza collana non
potevamo fare
nominate non dispiaceva però da si
esponeva tutte allora la cosa importante
è quella di continuare a tagliare finché
veramente piccolino perché in modo che
si sciolga bene bene bene il formato una
ricetta orribile cioè ci siete voi che
dovete rompere le fa smettiamola subito
grazie va bene scusa record ma è già
gianmarco di iodio laccati pulisco
orario ragazzi non ho mai avuto così
tante persone che non vedono l'ora di
mettermi le cose ragazzi ho preso una
decisione
non voglio minimamente il formaggio il
tema di quest'anno nostra sono stufo di
fare questi abomini e quindi non lo farò
devi farlo non lo farò assolutamente non
lo farò lo farò sempre che vuol dire
seguente
che senza sicura
ti stavo aspettando gianmarco mai detto
seguin juve ne stiamo aspettando
ma è la viglia
metterai quel formaggio morirà ma è
anche tua cugina non interessa
c'è anche un video per tempo scorre
quando la fiamma della fiaccola magica
tornerà ad ardere più calda e luminosa
la prima è che quando la vernice
fiammante lavinia perché la rapida con
quei capelli banda la mia ho bisogno di
un anti crespo fumetti la mozzarella
della nave fosse un mostro lamine ti
salverò
e va bene e terrà il formaggio dentro
quella known as a questo punto mettiamo
la mozzarella aiutarle
sono felice spingi comprendi tutto quel
amicis il primo un'arma sport prendere
un certo punto samp nè mai
dieci minuti 21 ragazzi decimi li dentro
10 minuti dentro al volo dai dieci
minuti o vieni qui c'è un problema
uno dei tanti senti ricorda vulcano di
dello sketch triscari è carina
ammetto che non fa un brutto d'ora ci
stiamo tenendo conto nostra paura che
non fa un odore terribile il grimorio
atene adesso prendiamo la pancetta e lo
foderiamo completamente attorno i big
però prima di marzo sta incollato sto
coso è un po difficile preparare tutte
le striscette di essere molto delicato
gianni la dedica dell'esame che sia
proprio tunisia indica troppo difesa ma
è solo un etichetta che mi è stata
affidata ti prego mostra cittadina
organizza una del sand rossi problemi
passate comodo ma sembra salmone perché
affumicato che problemi ci aspetta è
sentito di presente sembra salmone
affumicato
oddio lega e salmone affumicato ma
quello è concludo ma se la giunta il
bacon crudo e senato salmone cioè quei
dello stremato in e uccidono a me capito
che ucciso loro figlio che è bellissima
stupenda ma centra un forno questo crack
occhionero raga prendono fuoco i capelli
che l'età
la stavano fumando ad essere una cosa da
criminali così secondo me si brucia
tutto questo metti questo qui è l'aver i
capelli sì sì così almeno questo lo
protegge bravissimi e poi ci montiamo
soprattutto quanto ai 175 gradi per 20
minuti
incrociamo le dita e successo un bacio
casinò ragazzi al piacere di presentarvi
un esposizione mediatica per ugo
esposito simone energetiche per cui
collo hanno messo in esposizione vi
chiedo di re a questo punto che arrivato
il momento di iscriversi a questo canale
mettere un like farci sapere cosa pensa
di questa ricetta ma soprattutto passare
all'assaggio beccate aspetta la
telecamera gianmarco e dice a nome di
ciriè che io sono mal da essa è solo un
etichetta che mi è stato affidato a
trovarsi
allora proviamo a vedere succede filante
nelle più da un pezzo corso dicono ha
sbagliato non è molto appetitoso in
realtà nemmeno nel menu scempio
tagliarlo non è stato facile allora si
presenta in maniera orribile gli effetto
si presenta male ma secondo me di sapore
si presenta peggio fa cagare veramente
cagare il coltello diverso jam piatto fa
cagare lavato il coltello davanti a
tutti è come una bella ragazza un bel
ragazzo che poi si scoprirà una
personalità di media partiamo con
l'assaggio iniziamo con un bel taglio
cosa il tuo quello the money autore
particolare perché appena lo aprì senti
questa botta di ananas che prima non
senti perché la tutta quanta tappata
arrivano dei sapori improvviso formaggio
un posto aveva nascosto
forse ho preso poka poka ananas che
sinceramente mi aspettavo peggio non
posso dire che è strano sono sapori così
un conflitto l'uno con l'altro che bo è
come se mangiassi tre piatti versi non
mi aspettavo peggio secondo assaggio gli
piace ma non ha il coraggio di dirla
road una seconda volta
come dico che l'ho trovato gustoso ma
niente di così tragico e l'ananas cosa
proprio a meraviglia contributi fatto
c'è un qualcosa interessante ok secondo
assaggio un po più horror perché si
sente raanana 66 linguaggio
sostanzialmente aspetto 2 bruttissima
l'aspetto inverno terribile ben sette da
vestita 4 la sfogliata 2 veramente
brutto diverso da quel che si vede
quindi vorrei premiarlo tre e mezzo di
una bruttezza poi quando l'ho visto
quando il piatto veramente ha fatto
dietro a un sapore si alternano momenti
di momenti di 36 rispetto agli altri due
è la cosa che mi ha turbato di meno se
non fosse per l'ananas sarebbe
sufficiente voglio sconcertarsi con il
sapore è quatre dignitosissima alla
merda conto dai 5 a 4 e mezzo un 4 meno
odore 42 ci aggiriamo tra i due il 2 e
mezzo due camere d'aria non perdere
settimo pessimo pentima quanto sei
disposto a pagare per questo piatto 20
euro se me li danno
ramsey mi accodo alla tua decisione
mille euro al mese possano andar bene
vidoli un bar per questo reato pagherei
diecimila lire
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video noi come sempre vi mandiamo
un abbraccio grande e ci vediamo questo
martedì alle 12
con il taglio di capelli di gianmarco
ecco che la cosa più tragica aregai che
mutato per include magnate messa cioè io
già sto maglia sinceramente hackett e
sapere
[Risate]